From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. I'm joined in the studio right now by my coworker, Tobin Low. Hey there, Tobin.
来自芝加哥WBEZ电台，这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。此时此刻，我的同事托宾·洛和我一起在演播室。你好啊，托宾。
Hi, Ira.
你好，艾拉。
And I'm just going to say that the story you're about to tell, you acknowledge the existence of sex, but that's really all that you acknowledge, that it exists. Tell me what happened.
我只想说，关于你接下来要讲的那个故事，你承认性行为的存在，但你承认的也就仅此而已，仅仅是它存在。说说发生了什么吧。
Yeah, OK. So this guy, Paul, this happened when he was in his early 20s. And he arranges this hookup with a guy he meets online. And I should say, the guy, his profile doesn't have that much info. It says he's closeted, that if they're going to meet up, it has to be very discreet.
好的，没问题。这个叫保罗的家伙，这事发生在他20出头的时候。他通过网络约了一个人。我得说，那个人的个人资料里并没有太多信息。上面写着他是隐秘的，如果他们要见面，必须非常谨慎。
He said I couldn't go over to his place. And I also had a roommate, so it would have been difficult for me to host him as well. So he told me, I know a spot. I know a spot that we can go. Why don't you just meet me at these cross streets at 10 o'clock. And I said, OK, works for me. And so I drove over at night to where he told me to meet him.
他说我不能去他住的地方。而且我也有室友，所以我也很难招待他。于是他告诉我，我知道一个地方。我知道一个我们可以去的地方。你为什么不10点钟在这些十字路口跟我碰头呢。我说，好的，没问题。于是我晚上开车去了他告诉我的见面地点。
I get to the cross streets, and he isn't there. There's nobody there. And so I think, OK, no worries. He's running late. I'll just hang around for a bit.
我到了十字路口，但他不在那儿。那儿一个人也没有。所以我心想，好吧，别担心。他迟到了。我就在附近转转。
And so finally, he sees this guy standing on a corner, and the guy beckons for him to pull over.
终于，他看到一个人站在街角，那个人向他招手示意他靠边停车。
And I'm like, OK, great, confirmation. It's him, perfect. And I lower the window. And I say to him, oh, sorry about that. I just wasn't sure if it was you. And he was like, don't sweat it. It's all good. And he gets in my car.
我心想，好的，太棒了，确认了。是他，完美。我摇下车窗，对他说，噢，抱歉，刚才不太确定是不是你。他回道，别紧张，没事的。然后他就上了我的车。
So Paul asks him, where are we going? And the guy starts to direct him to the hookup spot, like, make a left up there, turn right at this corner.
于是保罗问他，我们要去哪儿？那个人开始指引他去那个约会地点，比如，在那儿左转，在那儿右转。
Things started to feel a little weird when several minutes passed, and we were still driving because I had been under the assumption that this secret spot would have been around the corner or something.
几分钟过去后，事情开始变得有点奇怪，我们还在一直开车，因为我一直以为那个秘密地点就在拐角处之类的地方。
So then I ask him, well, where are we going? And then he says, Glendale. Now, if you're not familiar with LA, I mean, the place where I picked him up was in Franklin Village. And Glendale isn't super, super far, but it's still close to a 20-minute drive. Something must not be adding up here. And then I start to second guess everything that had happened on that ride so far. Why wasn't he at the spot when he said he would be? He was a little bit further up. So then that was also weird.
所以我问他，我们到底要去哪儿？然后他说，格伦代尔。如果你不熟悉洛杉矶，我的意思是，我接他的地方是在富兰克林村。格伦代尔其实不算特别远，但开车也要近20分钟。有些事情肯定不对劲。然后我开始重新审视那次车程中发生的一切。为什么他约定的时间他不准时出现？他当时还在更远一点的地方。那也很奇怪。
And then he realizes--
然后他意识到——
This must not be the guy. There's no way that this is the guy I'm supposed to be meeting.
这绝对不是那个人。我不可能约的是这个人。
And so was he scared? Did he think this guy might rob him or hurt him in some way?
那么他当时害怕吗？他有没有想过这个人可能会抢劫他或伤害他？
He doesn't have time to be scared because he pretty immediately realizes exactly what's happened, why a guy would wave you down and get into your car.
他没时间害怕，因为他很快就反应过来到底发生了什么，为什么一个人会向你招手并坐进你的车里。
This was a total stranger to me who was there waiting for his rideshare driver.
这是一个我完全不认识的陌生人，他在那儿等他的网约车司机。
See, once you say that, it seems totally obvious.
看，一旦你这么说，这事儿就显得太显而易见了。
I know. You would think, right? But can I present to you Paul's defense of himself?
我知道。你肯定会这么想，对吧？但我能为你呈现一下保罗的自我辩护吗？
Please.
请讲。
So first of all, this was 2013. So if you remember, that's early in rideshare culture. So the whole dance that happens where you wave down a driver, you get in, and people know what to say to each other--
首先，那是2013年。如果你还记得的话，那是网约车文化的早期。所以那种招手示意司机、上车，然后大家心照不宣该说什么的整套流程——
That just wasn't in his head in the same way back then.
当时并没有在他脑子里形成那样的概念。
Exactly. The other thing is that the guy that he was supposed to meet up with, his hookup, the photo on the profile was kind of grainy, and he was wearing sunglasses in the photo. So Paul actually didn't have a clear picture in his mind of what the guy was supposed to look like.
没错。另一件事是，他本来要见的那个人，也就是他的约会对象，个人资料上的照片有点模糊，而且照片里那人戴着墨镜。所以保罗实际上并不清楚那人到底长什么样。
Oh, OK.
哦，好吧。
Yeah. Though there is one more thing that's a little bit more of an obvious giveaway.
是啊。不过还有一件事更让人觉得明显。
I always feel a little bit silly when people point out that he got in my back seat.
每当人们指出他是坐进我的后座时，我总是觉得有点蠢。
Oh, he got in the back seat of the car.
哦，他是坐进了后座。
He got in my back seat. But I invite you to look at it from my perspective because I thought that in a matter of moments, I was going to be joining him in the back seat. So I didn't think it was that weird. He was just preemptively getting in the back, and--
他坐进了我的后座。但我邀请你换个角度看，因为我当时认为，很快我就要和他一起坐在后座了。所以我没觉得那有什么奇怪的。他只是提前坐到了后座，而且——
Oh, he's just-- he's thinking ahead. He's 10 steps ahead of you.
哦，他只是——他想得比较远。他比你领先了10步。
He's thinking ahead. It's the more spacious part of the car. And I didn't even know the name of the person I was meeting, so it's not like I could have been like, hey, are you Andrew or whatever?
他在提前规划。那是车里更宽敞的部分。而且我甚至不知道我要见的那个人叫什么名字，所以我也没法问，嘿，你是安德鲁还是什么的吗？
Oh. You didn't have a name to go off--
噢。你连名字都不知道——
I didn't--
我不知道——
--either.
——也对。
Yeah, yeah. He could have gotten in and been like, hey, are you here for Dave? And I would have been like, well, I don't know. I guess I am.
是的，是的。他本来可能上车后说，嘿，你是来接戴夫的吗？我会回答，嗯，我不知道。我想我是吧。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
So now Paul has to make a decision. Is he going to say something?
所以现在保罗必须做一个决定。他是要说点什么吗？
I have no idea what to do because part of me wants to pull over and say to him, there's been a huge mistake. But then I realized that if I were to do that, I would have a lot of explaining to do because he would have wanted to know, why did I let him in my car?
我不知道该怎么办，因为我内心一部分想要靠边停车并对他说，出了个大错。但后来我意识到如果我真的那么做了，我将会有很多麻烦要解释，因为他会想知道，我为什么要让他上我的车？
Also, I should say by now, they've been driving in the car together for several minutes. So it's way past the threshold for a lighthearted oops, misunderstanding.
另外，我得说，那时候他们已经在车里一起开了几分钟了。所以早就过了轻描淡写地说声“哎呀，误会了”的那个节点。
[LAUGHTER] Yeah.
[笑声] 是的。
And then Paul, he has this more alarming thought.
然后保罗，他有一个更令他不安的想法。
If this is what I think and this is somebody who is, in fact, just waiting for his Uber, then the actual driver is going to be pulling up and trying to find him any second now. Not even two seconds later, as soon as I had that realization, his phone rings.
如果我想的是对的，而这确实是个等着坐优步的人，那么真正的司机很快就会赶到并尝试找他。甚至不到两秒钟后，就在我产生那个想法的时候，他的电话响了。
Oh my God.
天哪。
My heart stops because I know what it's going to be before he even picks it up. I know it's going to be his driver telling him that he's here. And I feel so foolish, and I feel so embarrassed because I thought I was about to be outed. I panicked, and my heart was racing, and I did not know what to do. And then he picks up the phone.
我的心跳停了，因为在他接听之前我就知道那是什么电话。我知道那会是他的司机告诉他到了。我感到非常愚蠢，也非常尴尬，因为我以为自己差点就要暴露了。我很惊慌，心跳加速，我不知道该做什么。然后他接了电话。
And what does he say?
他说了什么？
He's saying things like, huh? What do you mean? I don't understand. What do you mean you're outside?
他说，哈？你是什么意思？我不明白。你说的你在外面是什么意思？
Oh my god.
天哪。
And he was like, huh, that's so weird. I'm already in the car.
然后他说，哈，太奇怪了。我已经上车了。
And then Paul has this total perspective shift because now he's thinking about, how is this going to look from the backseat of the car?
然后保罗产生了一种彻底的视角转换，因为现在他在想，从后座看会是什么样子？
That would be so frightening to be sitting in your Uber, get a call from your driver saying that they're outside, and then you look at the details of what car you're supposed to be looking for and what your driver looks like, see that your driver is not that person and the car is not that vehicle. If I were him, I would have thought, OK, I'm being kidnapped. Or what is happening right now?
如果坐在优步里，接到司机打来的电话说他在外面，然后你查看自己该找的车牌信息和司机长相，发现司机不是那个人，车子也不是那辆车，那会非常可怕。如果我是他，我会觉得，OK，我被绑架了。或者现在到底发生了什么？
So the guy hangs up the phone. And it's at this point that Paul gets this gift from the gods.
所以那个人挂了电话。就在这时，保罗得到了来自上帝的礼物。
He says to me, do they ever send two drivers? Immediately, I was just like, yeah, sometimes there's a glitch. Sometimes there's a glitch, and they send two drivers. That's what happened.
他对我说，他们会派两辆车吗？我立刻就说，是的，有时候会有系统故障。有时候系统故障，他们会派两辆车过来。这就是发生的事情。
I can't believe he gets saved.
我真不敢相信他被救了。
I know. And for the rest of the drive, he commits to the part. He is Paul the Uber driver, which means he plays along as the guy in the back tries to make conversation.
我知道。在接下来的车程中，他一直坚持演下去。他是保罗，优步司机，这意味着他得陪着后座那个人试图聊天。
Oh, how long have you been driving? Do you like it? Do you get paid well? Do you meet interesting people? Just things like that.
哦，你开了多久了？你喜欢这份工作吗？薪水高吗？你会遇到有趣的人吗？诸如此类的。
And how are you answering?
那你怎么回答？
I was just making things up. Yeah, I've been dri-- not too long. It's all right. I got paid all right. The people are nice. I was just completely making it all up. The funny thing is, though, that because I didn't know whether he thought I was Uber or Lyft or some other rideshare, I had to be kind of vague because I didn't want to say, oh, yeah, Uber is great. And then he'd be like, wait, I thought this was a Lyft? And I'd be like, uhhh...that's what I mean.
我只是在编故事。是的，我已经开了……没太久。还行吧。薪水还可以。人们都很友好。我完全是在胡编乱造。不过有趣的是，因为我不知道他认为我是优步还是Lyft或者是其他什么网约车，我不得不说得很模糊，因为我不想说，噢，是的，优步太棒了。然后他会说，等等，我还以为这是Lyft？那我就会回答，额……这就是我的意思。
The lucky thing for Paul is that because he asked for directions when the guy first got in the car, the guy doesn't really notice that Paul doesn't have the app open or the GPS open. He's just comfortable giving him directions all the way to Glendale. So eventually, they do end up at his house.
幸运的是，因为那人在刚上车时问了方向，他并没有真正注意到保罗没打开App或导航。他很放心地指引保罗一路开到了格伦代尔。所以最终，他们确实到达了他家。
And then as he's getting out of the car, I did-- part of me, a tiny, tiny part of me, was thinking still, is this the guy? Is he about to invite me inside? Just trying to hold on to any glimmer of this making sense.
然后当他下车时，我——我内心中很小很小的一部分，仍然在想，这会是那个人吗？他要邀请我进去吗？只是试图抓住任何这事儿说得通的微光。
And then incredibly, the guy does invite him up.
然后不可思议的是，那个人确实邀请他上楼了。
He does.
他真的邀请了。
He does. And actually, they are still together today.
确实。而且实际上，他们今天还在一起。
Really?
真的吗？
No. Of course not. The guy just wishes him a good night and goes into his house.
不。当然没有。那个人只是祝他晚安，然后就进屋了。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
That's it. And the next day, Paul got a message from his actual hookup, and it turns out, the guy just got scared and decided not to come. But to this day, Paul still stands by his decision.
就这样。第二天，保罗收到了他真正的约会对象的消息，结果那个人只是害怕了，决定不来了。但直到今天，保罗仍然坚持他的决定。
You know what? I think it is for the best that I didn't set the record straight.
你知道吗？我觉得我没有澄清事实是最好的结果。
Because in that case, he just had a totally normal night.
因为那样的话，他只是度过了一个完全正常的夜晚。
He had a totally normal night. And you know what? He got a free ride.
他度过了一个完全正常的夜晚。而且你知道吗？他还坐了一次免费车。
It's hard to decide to set the record straight. The world usually does not want to hear it. It is almost always an inconvenient truth. Today on our program, we have people who step up, tell the truth the rest of us have not heard and sometimes do not want to hear, and let the chips fall where they may. Stay with us.
决定澄清事实是很难的。世界通常不想听真相。这几乎总是令人不快的真相。今天在我们的节目中，我们会介绍那些站出来讲述我们其他人没听过、有时也不想听的真相，并任由事态发展的人。请继续收听。
Act 1, Home Test. So we begin today with a kid, 12 years old. He's trying to figure out the truth, to set things straight for himself. This boy, Ilya, his family had recently escaped from Mariupol in Ukraine. Mariupol was a city that you may remember, back in the spring, everybody was trying to get out of. It was under siege for months. Food was running out. The Russians bombed a maternity and children's hospital, then a theater that people were using as a bomb shelter. Soldiers and civilians made a long last stand at the steel plant. There were lots of failed attempts to set up a humanitarian corridor. Big parts of the city were destroyed.
第一幕，家庭测试。所以我们今天从一个12岁的孩子开始。他试图弄清事实，为自己澄清一切。这个男孩，伊利亚，他的家人最近刚从乌克兰马里乌波尔逃出来。马里乌波尔是你们可能还记得的一座城市，春天的时候，每个人都在试图逃离。它被围困了几个月。食物快耗尽了。俄军轰炸了妇产医院和儿童医院，然后是一个被人们用作防空洞的剧院。士兵和平民在钢铁厂进行了漫长的最后抵抗。有很多建立人道主义走廊的尝试都失败了。城市的大部分地区都被摧毁了。
Ilya and his family managed to escape all that. They made it to Poland. And then last month, incredibly, they decided they wanted to go back to Mariupol to see if their old home was a place that they could still live. Producer Valerie Kipnis talked to Ilya about what happened.
伊利亚和他的家人设法逃过了这一切。他们到达了波兰。然后上个月，令人难以置信的是，他们决定想回到马里乌波尔，看看他们的老家是否还是一个他们可以继续居住的地方。制片人瓦莱丽·基普尼斯与伊利亚谈论了所发生的事情。
I met Ilya while I was volunteering at a refugee center in Warsaw this past spring.
我是在今年春天于华沙的一个难民中心做志愿者时遇到伊利亚的。
[CHILDREN SHOUT]
[儿童喧闹声]
One rainy day in June, I was showing a couple kids how to use a camera and interview one another when Ilya walked into the room. I could tell he was interested but too shy to say much. I asked if he wanted to join us. And one of the younger kids asked if they could interview him. They were eager to try with someone new. He shrugged and plopped himself in front of the camera.
六月的一个下雨天，我正在教几个孩子如何使用相机并互相采访，这时伊利亚走进房间。我看得出他很感兴趣，但又太害羞说不出话。我问他是否想加入我们。其中一个年幼的孩子问能不能采访他。他们很渴望尝试采访新人。他耸了耸肩，坐在相机前。
You could tell that outside of war times, Ilya was a cool kid. It was something about the way he carried himself.
你可以看出，在战争时期之外，伊利亚是个很酷的孩子。他举手投足之间有些特别的东西。
[CHILDREN SHOUTING IN UKRAINIAN AND LAUGHING]
[孩子们用乌克兰语尖叫和笑声]
I remember thinking about how dark the rings were under his eyes. I double-checked as he sat in front of the camera. You sure you want to do this? Why not, he said. Julia, who's seven, asks his name and how old he is.
我记得想到他眼下的黑眼圈有多深。当他坐在相机前时，我再次确认了一下。你确定要这样做吗？为什么不呢，他说。七岁的茱莉亚问他的名字和年龄。
Ilya replies--
伊利亚回答说——
[RUSSIAN SPEECH]
[俄语对话]
--my name is Ilya, and I'm 12 years old. My city is Mariupol. I was born in Mariupol. I've lived there for a span of 12 years-- all of them, I lived there, until the orcs fell on us, that is. That's how I'm going to name such unpleasant characters.
——我叫伊利亚，今年12岁。我的城市是马里乌波尔。我出生在马里乌波尔。我在那里生活了12年——全部的时光，我都在那儿，直到那些兽人袭击我们为止。我打算用这个词来称呼那些令人厌恶的角色。
The orcs are his way of saying Russian soldiers.
“兽人”是他称呼俄国士兵的方式。
Then he tells the room--
然后他告诉房间里的人——
[RUSSIAN SPEECH]
[俄语对话]
--your second question is probably going to be about my feelings about the war.
——你的第二个问题可能关于我对战争的感受。
And then he went on to answer his own question. He described watching Azovstal, the massive steel factory near his house that the Russians bombed for months, as it burned for days on end, about how he had hid in a basement while snipers fired at his home, right into their windows.
然后他继续回答了他自己的问题。他描述了看着他家附近的巨大的钢铁厂——亚速钢铁厂，那是被俄军轰炸了几个月的工厂——连续几天燃烧的情景，描述了当狙击手对着他的家、对着他们的窗户射击时，他躲在地窖里的感受。
Ilya says the scariest feeling was when he finally made it to his grandma's house, a house he spent a lot of time in, and it was completely burned down. There were corpses of people laying outside all around. He didn't know if his grandma was alive or not.
伊利亚说，最可怕的感觉是他终于到达奶奶家时——那个他花了很多时间的地方——却发现房子被彻底烧毁了。外面到处都是尸体。他不知道奶奶是否还活着。
[RUSSIAN SPEECH]
[俄语对话]
We came to my grandma's, and we couldn't enter because the house was completely mined. It wasn't until hours later he found out his grandmother had survived. Here, Zhenya, the 11-year-old filming him, stopped recording. Ilya covered his face with his Angry Birds t-shirt.
我们来到奶奶家，但进不去，因为房子完全被埋了地雷。几小时后，他才发现奶奶幸存了下来。这时，拍摄他的11岁的热尼亚停止了录音。伊利亚用他的愤怒的小鸟T恤遮住了脸。
It was remarkable to me that he had made it out of Mariupol. In all the time I was in Poland, I didn't meet anyone else from his city. Ilya and his family made it to one of Warsaw's nicer refugee centers, which offer them long-term housing. Doctors, lawyers, teachers, and psychiatrists would come in to help on site. There was food and a playroom for kids. It was safe, well-run, orderly.
他能从马里乌波尔逃出来，这让我感到非常了不起。我在波兰期间，没遇到过其他来自他那座城市的人。伊利亚和他的家人设法进入了华沙条件较好的难民中心之一，这些中心为他们提供了长期住宿。医生、律师、教师和心理学家会来现场提供帮助。那里有食物和儿童游戏室。那里安全、管理有序、井井有条。
The day I met Ilya, he asked for my number right away. That's just the kind of kid he is, a little businessman. Sometimes in the mornings, if I was late to my shift, he would call me to make sure I was still coming and then confirm a time to be exact. He would then inform the others. When I would arrive at the shelter, he would be waiting for me outside.
我遇到伊利亚的那天，他立刻就问了我的电话号码。他就是那种孩子，像个小商人。有时在早晨，如果我的轮班迟到了，他会打电话给我确认我是否还会来，然后确定一个具体的时间。他会告诉其他人。当我到达庇护所时，他会在外面等我。
But Ilya was also more reserved than the other kids. He couldn't always break out of his quiet. When he did, he would get into long conversations with me, using phrases like, listen here, Val, or you got to hear me out, Val.
但伊利亚也比其他孩子更内向。他并不总能打破沉默。当他打破沉默时，他会和我进行长时间的交谈，使用像“听着，瓦尔”或“瓦尔，你得听我说完”这样的短语。
[RUSSIAN SPEECH]
[俄语对话]
After months of hanging out with Ilya and the other kids, I had to go back to the States. On my last night working at the shelter, as Ilya walked me to the tram stop, which had become our daily tradition, he chased me with a water gun and laughed. He seemed to be getting used to Poland.
在和伊利亚以及其他孩子们相处了几个月后，我必须回到美国。我在庇护所工作的最后一个晚上，当伊利亚送我到有轨电车站时——这已经成了我们的日常习惯——他拿着水枪追着我跑，笑个不停。他似乎开始习惯波兰了。
[CHILDREN LAUGH AND SHOUT]
[孩子们欢笑和尖叫]
But a few weeks later, he called to say that his family-- him, his mom, dad, and sister-- were making plans to go back, back to Mariupol.
但几周后，他打电话说他的家人——他，他的妈妈，爸爸和妹妹——正在计划回去，回到马里乌波尔。
I hadn't heard of any families like Ilya's who'd managed to escape Mariupol and make it all the way to safety in Poland to then try and return. After all, the city was badly damaged and now under Russian control. And the shelter they were in, it was one of the better ones, the ones most wanted to get into. I called Ilya's mom.
我没听说过有像伊利亚这样设法逃离马里乌波尔并一路抵达波兰安全地带，然后又试图返回的家庭。毕竟，这座城市受损严重，现在处于俄罗斯控制之下。而且他们所处的庇护所是条件最好的那一类，大多数人挤破头都想进去。我给伊利亚的妈妈打了电话。
[RUSSIAN SPEECH]
[俄语对话]
She told me that last week, it was Ilya and his sister's birthdays. They didn't want birthday parties, she said. They didn't want anything, no presents. The only thing that they wanted for their birthday were tickets home. I asked her, have you been trying to prepare your children for the fact that things may be different?
她告诉我，上周是伊利亚和他妹妹的生日。他们不想要生日派对，她说。他们什么也不要，不要礼物。他们生日唯一的愿望就是回家的票。我问她，你有没有试图让孩子们做好准备，面对事情可能已经不同的事实？
[RUSSIAN SPEECH]
[俄语对话]
She said, yeah. I tell them, look how beautiful Warsaw is. Look at everything we have here. When we come home, it's not going to be beautiful like this. She says she tells them that they're not going to have ice cream. And the kids say, we don't need any of this. We're ready to eat what we have. We just want to go home.
她说，有。我告诉他们，看看华沙有多美。看看我们这里拥有的一切。当我们回家时，它不会像这里这么美。她说她告诉孩子们他们不会有冰淇淋。孩子们说，我们不需要这些。我们准备好吃我们所拥有的。我们只想回家。
The truth is, Ilya's mom felt the same way as her kids. She told me she'd rather wake up in her own home than stay in Poland. They'd been on the run for months, stayed at so many temporary places, and she felt no relief or comfort. And also-- this was a big part of it-- she felt an obligation to her own parents, who she'd left behind. But she also worried about what it would be like for her kids to see the city so changed. They'll have to come to their own conclusions, she said.
事实上，伊利亚的妈妈和她的孩子们有同样的感觉。她告诉我，她宁愿在自己的家里醒来，也不愿待在波兰。他们逃亡了几个月，住在许多临时的地方，她没感觉到任何宽慰或舒适。而且——这也是很重要的部分——她感到对留在身后的父母有义务。但她也担心孩子们看到城市发生如此大的变化会是什么心情。她说，他们必须自己得出结论。
I talked to Ilya for a while about it.
我和伊利亚聊了一会儿这件事。
[RUSSIAN SPEECH]
[俄语对话]
He said he wanted to go home because that's where his grandma is. He said, I'd rather be home where sure, conditions aren't great, but I can do as I like, than just be like a little cat here, not knowing my place. Prior to the war, Ilya had spent most of his time living at his grandparents' house because his parents work so much. When he and his parents fled Mariupol, it was the first time he had left his grandma in his entire life.
他说他想回家，因为奶奶在那里。他说，我宁愿待在家里，虽然那里的条件并不太好，但我可以随心所欲，而不是像只小猫一样待在这里，不知道自己的位置。在战争之前，伊利亚大部分时间都住在祖父母家，因为他的父母工作太忙。当他和父母逃离马里乌波尔时，这是他一生中第一次离开奶奶。
[RUSSIAN SPEECH]
[俄语对话]
I'm worried about only one thing, Ilya said. I really don't want to go back to school. He said he wasn't worried about anything that might happen within the classroom. He was worried about actually getting there. He had heard that there were mines everywhere. He said it freaked him out.
我只担心一件事，伊利亚说。我真的不想回到学校。他说他不担心课堂内可能会发生什么。他担心的是如何到达学校。他听说到处都是地雷。他说这让他非常害怕。
[RUSSIAN SPEECH]
[俄语对话]
He didn't like his parents leaving him to go to work at the factory for the same reason and told me he'd come up with a plan to start a business there so they could all work together, selling backpacks and knickknacks at the flea market or something.
他不希望父母留他一人去工厂工作，原因也是一样。他告诉我他想出了一个计划，在那儿开始做生意，这样他们就能一起工作，在跳蚤市场上卖背包和小玩意儿之类的东西。
Ilya actually expected home to be different. He was aware that Russia had fully occupied his city and saw in social media that now even the sign at the entrance that said Mariupol had been changed.
伊利亚实际上预料到家乡会变得不同。他意识到俄罗斯已经全面占领了他的城市，并在社交媒体上看到，现在连入口处写着“马里乌波尔”的牌子都被改了。
[RUSSIAN SPEECH]
[俄语对话]
OK, now, now, look at the first photo. That's what they've changed it to. And now look at the second photo. It says Mariupol. And instead of a Ukrainian E, they added a Russian E. So they've already renamed it. Mariupol used to be Mariupol. Now, it's Mariupol.
好了，现在，看看第一张照片。那是他们改成什么样了。现在看看第二张照片。它写着“马里乌波尔”（俄语拼法）。他们用一个俄语字母替换了乌克兰字母。所以他们已经重命名了。马里乌波尔过去是马里乌波尔。现在是马里乌波尔。
Ilya told me he and his sister had been fighting about that. His sister thought that when they got home, they should just make peace with the fact that Mariupol as they knew it was now over, that the Russians had won, that this was their new life. Ilya refused to accept defeat. The Russians were the ones who destroyed the city. He figured Ukrainians would keep on fighting. All in all, he had mixed feelings about returning.
伊利亚告诉我，他和妹妹一直在为这件事争吵。他的妹妹认为，当他们回家时，他们应该接受这样一个事实：他们所认识的马里乌波尔已经结束了，俄国人赢了，这就是他们的新生活。伊利亚拒绝接受失败。是俄国人摧毁了这座城市。他认为乌克兰人会继续战斗。总之，对于回归，他心情复杂。
[RUSSIAN SPEECH]
[俄语对话]
I want to go, and I don't want to go, he's saying, 50% one way, 50% the other.
他正说，我想去，我也不想去，百分之五十去，百分之五十不去。
[RUSSIAN SPEECH]
[俄语对话]
This is the thing he was trying to set straight for himself. Was Mariupol still going to feel like home?
这就是他试图为自己理清的事情。马里乌波尔还能让他感到像家吗？
Two days later, mid-August, Ilya texted me from the road. By the way, he wrote, we're already en route home. I don't know when I'll be able to write to you again. And then radio silence. I couldn't get a hold of Ilya or his mother. I stayed up into the morning hours scrolling through Ukrainian Telegram channels made for this exact reason. Had there been a bombing, a missile strike that I had missed?
两天后，八月中旬，伊利亚在路上给我发了短信。顺便说一下，他写道，我们已经在回家的路上了。我不知道什么时候能再写信给你。然后就是无线电静默。我联系不上伊利亚或他的母亲。我熬到凌晨，滚动浏览为这个目的建立的乌克兰Telegram频道。是有轰炸吗，我错过了导弹袭击吗？
But then a couple days later, Ilya popped up on my screen. He wrote to me of bad news. The border guards hadn't let his mom and sister into Ukraine because of a document issue. So the family decided to split up. His mom and sister returned back to Warsaw while he and his dad continued to Mariupol. And then a few days later, another text message came through. Ilya had made it. He wrote me an update the way he always texted, in long, run-on sentences.
但几天后，伊利亚出现在我的屏幕上。他给我写了坏消息。边防警卫因为文件问题没让他的妈妈和妹妹进入乌克兰。所以家庭决定分开。他的妈妈和妹妹回到了华沙，而他和爸爸继续前往马里乌波尔。几天后，另一条短信发了过来。伊利亚到了。他像往常一样给我发了更新，用的是长长的、连贯的句子。
Their apartment had light and water, though the internet was spotty, and there was no gas, but they'd bought an electric stove yesterday. So no more of that. On the first day back, he made sure to see his grandmother. They hugged and drank tea together, just like old times. He walked around the neighborhood with his dad. He told me he was nervous about filming outside because the soldiers didn't like it when people did that. Even so, he insisted on sending me at least one video.
他们的公寓有电有水，虽然网络不稳定，而且没有燃气，但他们昨天买了电炉。所以不用担心那个了。回家的第一天，他特意去看了奶奶。他们像过去一样拥抱并喝茶。他和爸爸在附近散步。他告诉我，他在外面拍摄感到很紧张，因为士兵们不喜欢人们这么做。尽管如此，他还是坚持给我发了至少一个视频。
[RUSSIAN SPEECH]
[俄语对话]
Ilya's hand is shaky, as if he's trying to keep his phone hidden. But I can still make out the image, a large collapsed building next to a bus stop, Ilya's his favorite supermarket. The only thing left of it? Its metal beams.
伊利亚的手在颤抖，好像在试图隐藏他的手机。但我还是能分辨出图像，公交车站旁边倒塌的大型建筑，伊利亚最喜欢的超市。剩下的只有什么？它的金属梁。
[RUSSIAN SPEECH]
[俄语对话]
Later, we talked on the phone. He told me, I lived in the city for 11 years, and I got used to certain things. And now, nothing really works like it used to.
后来，我们通了电话。他告诉我，我在城里住了11年，我习惯了某些事情。现在，没有什么是像以前那样运作的了。
It's all broken down, he said. But there are new houses being built. I mean, you hear shots being fired from the distance. They're demining a lot right now. And then today at 8:00, we heard machine gun rounds being fired.
一切都坏了，他说。但有新房在建。我的意思是，你能听到远处有枪声。他们现在正在排雷。今天8点钟，我们听到了机枪扫射的声音。
[RUSSIAN SPEECH]
[俄语对话]
Where from? I asked.
从哪儿传来的？我问。
[RUSSIAN SPEECH]
[俄语对话]
Well, not from far away. Nearby. When he went to the cemetery with his dad to visit some family who had been killed during the war, he was shocked.
嗯，离得不远。就在附近。当他和爸爸去墓地看望一些在战争中遇难的亲人时，他被震惊了。
[RUSSIAN SPEECH]
[俄语对话]
He told me, I went to the cemetery, and there were so many graves. I can't even describe it to you. You can't even count them. It was so many. And this is only at one cemetery.
他告诉我，我去墓地，那里有太多的坟墓。我甚至无法形容。你甚至数不清。太多了。这只是在一个墓地。
[RUSSIAN SPEECH]
[俄语对话]
We left some flowers, some candies, some cookies, a drink, and some cigarettes because my mom's cousin and her husband, they used to smoke. And so that's a tradition. You just leave them each one cigarette. According to local officials, the Russian siege of Mariupol killed at least 22,000 people and maybe a lot more.
我们放了一些花、一些糖果、饼干、饮料和香烟，因为我妈妈的表妹和她的丈夫过去常抽烟。所以这是一个传统。你只要给他们每人留一支烟。根据当地官员的说法，俄罗斯对马里乌波尔的围困导致至少22000人死亡，甚至可能更多。
[RUSSIAN SPEECH]
[俄语对话]
Ilya and I talked a lot over the past few weeks, and as time went on, I began to notice something in our calls. The things that once bothered him, the soldiers, the mines, his sister's attitude about the war, he started to describe them differently, like yes, lots of the city was a mess. But it didn't feel as bad as it had looked on his phone from Poland. He had light and electricity.
伊利亚和我过去几周谈了很多，随着时间的推移，我开始在我们的通话中注意到一些事情。曾经困扰他的事情，士兵、地雷、他妹妹对战争的态度，他开始以不同的方式描述它们，比如是的，城市里有很多乱七八糟的事情。但这并没有像他在波兰时在手机上看到的那样糟糕。他有光也有电。
And when I asked if he was still nervous about those mines on his walk to school, he said--
当我问他是否还在担心上学路上的那些地雷时，他说——
[RUSSIAN SPEECH]
[俄语对话]
--no, I've already been walking, and there's nothing there. The Russian soldiers just told me where to walk and where not to walk, so I've been listening to them. Ilya was now taking advice from the soldiers that occupied his city. I asked Ilya, are there lots of Russian soldiers there?
——不，我已经走过路了，那里什么都没有。俄罗斯士兵只是告诉我在哪儿走，在哪儿不走，所以我一直在听他们的话。伊利亚现在在听从占领他城市的士兵的建议。我问伊利亚，那里有很多俄罗斯士兵吗？
[RUSSIAN SPEECH]
[俄语对话]
Yeah, and then there's Chechens. And what, they just walk around the city? I asked. Yeah, they just walk around the city, to shops, to different places.
是的，还有车臣人。我问，什么，他们就在城里到处逛？是的，他们就在城里逛，去商店，去不同的地方。
[RUSSIAN SPEECH]
[俄语对话]
And how do they behave themselves?
他们的行为举止如何？
[RUSSIAN SPEECH]
[俄语对话]
Excellent. Polite. Honestly, when the Chechens are here and the kids come up to them, they give you money so you can buy candy. His mom told me the Chechens give him sodas and chips, anything the kids ask for.
非常出色。有礼貌。老实说，当车臣人在的时候，孩子们走过去，他们会给你钱让你买糖果。他的妈妈告诉我，车臣人给他汽水和薯片，孩子们要什么给什么。
[RUSSIAN SPEECH]
[俄语对话]
When I asked Ilya if it was weird for him that there are Russian soldiers everywhere, he told me, I already got used to it. You think they'll stay there forever or for now?
当我问伊利亚，到处都是俄罗斯士兵对他来说是否很奇怪时，他告诉我，我已经习惯了。你认为他们会永远待在那里还是暂时待在那里？
[RUSSIAN SPEECH]
[俄语对话]
Forever. Ilya told me he'd even made friends with some of the Russian and Chechen soldiers. It felt strange to hear him say that. He knows it was Russia that started all this. But they're the ones in charge now. And he told me people get killed for being pro-Ukraine.
永远。伊利亚告诉我，他甚至和一些俄罗斯和车臣士兵交了朋友。听到他说这话感觉很奇怪。他知道是俄罗斯挑起了一切。但现在他们掌权了。他告诉我，人们会因为支持乌克兰而丧命。
There are all kinds of things that don't make sense in Ilya's life right now. There are parts of town that are destroyed and parts that are fine. School's in session, but there are mines along the way. When you're living through a war, there's only so much you can set straight. You have to hold a lot of contradictions in your head at once. Ilya is getting pretty good at it.
伊利亚现在的生活中有各种各样不合理的事情。城里有的地方被毁了，有的地方还行。学校在开课，但沿途有地雷。当你经历战争时，你能理清的事情是有限的。你必须同时在脑海中容纳许多矛盾。伊利亚处理得相当好。
Valerie Kipnis is one of the producers of our show. Ilya's mom and sister finally did make it to Mariupol and surprised the grandparents. Ilya was there to film it.
瓦莱丽·基普尼斯是我们节目的制片人之一。伊利亚的妈妈和妹妹终于到达了马里乌波尔，并给了祖父母一个惊喜。伊利亚在那里录下了这一幕。
[KNOCKING]
[敲门声]
[JOYOUS CRIES]
[喜悦的喊声]
This week, Russian President Vladimir Putin signed a decree that made four regions of Ukraine into part of Russia officially, including where Ilya is right now. The United Nations Secretary General said the move went, quote, "against everything the international community is meant to stand for."
本周，俄罗斯总统弗拉基米尔·普京签署了一项法令，正式将乌克兰的四个地区划入俄罗斯，其中包括伊利亚现在所在的地方。联合国秘书长表示此举“违背了国际社会所代表的一切”。
Act 2, Oh, What a Hangled Web We Weave. Quick heads up before we start the story that it mentions part of the male anatomy. Take that under advisement, pro and con. Decide what you're going to do. It is not what the story is about. The story is about a creepy and dangerous creature that does all kinds of terrible things. It's also about somebody who takes issue with every word I just said about that creature. Lilly Sullivan met up with this person to hear her out.
第二幕，哦，我们编织了多么复杂的网。在开始故事前先快速提示一下，文中提到了男性解剖结构的一部分。请自行斟酌，利弊权衡。决定你要怎么做。这不是故事的主题。故事是关于一种可怕且危险的生物，它做了各种各样可怕的事情。这也是关于一个对我说的那种生物的一切说法都持有异议的人。莉莉·沙利文去见了这位人士，听听她的想法。
This person is my friend, Kelsey Padgett. And if you run into her at a dinner party or a bar, maybe you happen to be standing behind her in the security line at the airport, she might ask you this.
这个人是我的朋友，凯尔西·帕吉特。如果她在晚宴或酒吧遇到你，也许你碰巧站在机场安检排在她后面，她可能会问你这个。
What do you know about black widow spiders? What do you know?
你对黑寡妇蜘蛛了解多少？你知道些什么？
OK. I know that they are very poisonous. They have a really bad bite, like, a bite that can kill you. And I know that the female, after mating, kills the male and eats him.
好的。我知道它们非常有毒。它们的咬伤非常厉害，比如，咬一口就能要你的命。而且我知道雌性在交配后会杀掉雄性并吃掉它。
Fantastic. That is exactly what most people know about black widow spiders. And you're totally wrong.
太棒了。这就是大多数人对黑寡妇蜘蛛的了解。而你完全错了。
And this is Kelsey's mission, to expose the lies about this spider being a wanton murderess, correct the record, and restore her good name. Kelsey used to work as a park ranger in New York, by the way. She also used to report science stories. And over the years, she's amassed an absurd amount of information about these spiders.
这就是凯尔西的任务，揭露关于这种蜘蛛是残暴谋杀者的谎言，纠正记录，并恢复它的名声。顺便说一下，凯尔西曾经在纽约担任公园管理员。她也曾经报道过科学故事。多年来，她积累了关于这些蜘蛛的大量荒谬的信息。
So let me tell you. I'll start with the black widow name, the idea that the black widow eats her husband or the spider they just mated with, that she is a murderer dressed all in black, mourning a husband that they just killed.
所以我来告诉你。我先从黑寡妇的名字说起，这个想法——黑寡妇吃掉她的丈夫或者她们刚交配的蜘蛛，她是一个穿着全黑衣服、为刚杀死的丈夫哀悼的杀人犯。
Kelsey says the female eating the male, OK, this has happened, but very rarely. And it's barely a noticeable trait if you look around at what the rest of the spiders are doing.
凯尔西说，雌性吃掉雄性，好吧，这种情况发生过，但非常罕见。而且如果你看看其他蜘蛛在做什么，这几乎不是一个值得注意的特征。
Many species of baby spiders, which are called spiderlings, often eat their siblings right after hatching. And some species of spiderlings even eat their own mother after hatching.
许多幼年蜘蛛，也就是蜘蛛幼体，在孵化后经常吃掉它们的兄弟姐妹。而有些种类的蜘蛛幼体在孵化后甚至会吃掉它们自己的母亲。
Ugh.
呕。
And sexual cannibalism, which is eating your mate after he has done the deed with you, is very common in the spider world.
而且性食同类，也就是在完成交配后吃掉你的配偶，在蜘蛛世界非常普遍。
Ugh.
呕。
But you know who it's not common that much for is black widow spiders. They only do this in captivity. It's practically never been seen in the wild in the Northern Hemisphere.
但你知道谁这种情况不普遍吗？就是黑寡妇蜘蛛。它们只在圈养环境下才会这样做。在北半球的野外几乎从未被观察到过。
Meanwhile, the male spider, he's no Mr. Rogers. Check out what he does.
与此同时，雄性蜘蛛，他可不是什么好好先生。看看他在做什么。
So the male black widow will sometimes go around to the female's web and sort of clip off little parts of it so that she has no exit routes. And then he will go up next to her and calmly caress her. And then he throws a web of his own over her to then copulate with her.
雄性黑寡妇有时会绕到雌性的网上，剪掉它的一小部分，这样她就没了出口。然后他会走过去靠在她身边，冷静地爱抚她。然后他会把自己的网铺在她身上，以便随后与她交配。
Ugh.
呕。
And the scientists have called that web the bridal veil, which is so not what that should be called. Are you serious?
科学家们把那张网称为“新娘面纱”，这名字太不应该这样叫了。你是认真的吗？
Oh my god.
天哪。
But it strikes me as a very weird behavior. And if I were a person naming spiders and saw that sometimes the female ate the male after mating, but also that the male does this crazy thing and ties down the lady, basically, I might name the spider after that. But why didn't they? Because they were men, [LAUGHS] and they thought it was exceptional that the female killed the male. Oh my gosh. Can't have that.
但这在我看来是一种非常怪异的行为。如果我是给蜘蛛命名的人，看到有时雌性在交配后吃了雄性，但也看到雄性做这种疯狂的事情并基本上束缚住了女士，我可能会用这个命名这种蜘蛛。但他们为什么没这么做？因为他们是男人，[笑] 他们认为雌性杀掉雄性是例外的。天哪。不能容忍那样。
A lot of species of spiders do this bridal veil thing. One theory is the one Kelsey lays out, that the male is trapping the female. There's another newer one too, which is more accepted by scientists now, but it's more seduction than a trap. As a scientist put it when they explained it to me, it's bondage. Yep. Spiders do bondage.
很多种类的蜘蛛都会做这种“新娘面纱”的事情。一个理论是凯尔西提出的，即雄性在诱捕雌性。还有一个较新的理论，现在被科学家们所接受，但与其说是陷阱，不如说是诱惑。正如一位科学家向我解释时所说，这是束缚。没错。蜘蛛也会玩束缚。
Myth number two, that her bite is fatal.
第二个神话，她的咬伤是致命的。
So from 1950 to 1959, the data we have says that there were 63 deaths in the US from black widow spiders.
所以从1950年到1959年，我们掌握的数据显示，在美国有63人死于黑寡妇蜘蛛咬伤。
Interestingly, most of the black widow bite victims back then seem to be male. In an older study, they were 80% male. Here's a theory as to why.
有趣的是，当时的黑寡妇咬伤受害者大多是男性。在一项较早的研究中，他们占了80%。这里有一个原因理论。
So most of the reported black widow bites from this time happened in what were called outdoor privies, outhouses. So black widow spiders, they enjoy dark, low to the ground sort of places. They especially love to make their cobwebs between two objects.
当时报告的大多数黑寡妇咬伤都发生在所谓的“户外厕所”，即茅房。黑寡妇蜘蛛喜欢黑暗、离地近的地方。它们特别喜欢在两个物体之间织网。
And so because bugs like stinky places-- imagine flies, there's flies in outhouses-- that it makes a great food supply, right? And to get to the stinky stuff, you got to go through the bowl.
而且因为虫子喜欢臭味的地方——想象一下苍蝇，茅房里有苍蝇——这创造了极好的食物来源，对吧？要到臭的地方去，你得经过那个坑。
Right, right.
对，对。
So putting your web there is excellent. So imagine this. It's the 1950s. You're a dude. You need to go number two. You make your way out to the outhouse. You sit down, and your junk hangles there.
所以把网放在那儿很完美。所以想象一下。那是20世纪50年代。你是个男人。你需要上大号。你走到茅房。你坐下来，你的小兄弟挂在那儿。
Hangles. Yep. That's what she said.
挂在那儿。没错。这就是她说的。
And as it does, it hits the cobweb. And the usually non-aggressive black widow instinctually runs over and bites down on the new creature that has landed on its web.
当它挂着时，它碰到蜘蛛网。通常不具攻击性的黑寡妇本能地跑过去，咬住落在它网上的新生物。
Oh my god. That is kind of terrifying, though.
天哪。不过那确实有点恐怖。
It is, isn't it?
是啊，不是吗？
Yeah.
是的。
Yeah. There's not even-- you can't even imagine a better situation tailored to getting bit by this usually very non-aggressive spider. They don't come after you.
没错。你甚至无法想象还有什么比这更适合被这种通常非常不具攻击性的蜘蛛咬的情况了。它们不会主动追你。
And the statistic that you saw, how many bites were on penises?
而且你看到的那个统计数字，有多少咬伤是发生在丁丁上的？
The majority were on penises.
大多数都发生在丁丁上。
Oh my god.
天哪。
She thinks all these penis bites happening so regularly might be one of the reasons there were so many deaths back then.
她认为所有这些频繁发生的丁丁咬伤可能是当时死亡人数那么多的原因之一。
The skin there is less thick, and there are lots of nerves there. And this is a neurotoxin venom. So--
那里的皮肤较薄，且有很多神经。这是一种神经毒液。所以——
Oh, oh, oh.
哦，哦，哦。
Perhaps being bit on the genitals sends the venom going into your body in a faster or stronger way than, say, if you were bit on a callus on your foot.
也许在生殖器上被咬会导致毒液比你被咬在脚上的老茧更快或更强地进入你的身体。
Anyway, the point is, once more people had indoor plumbing along with improved access to medical care, the numbers, which weren't that high to begin with, they've gone way down. And in the last several decades, there's no record of anyone dying from a black widow spider-- no one.
无论如何，重点是，一旦更多人有了室内管道设施，再加上医疗护理的改善，这些数字，本来就没那么高，现在已经大幅下降了。在过去几十年里，没有任何人死于黑寡妇蜘蛛咬伤的记录——一个都没有。
In fact, the black widow is usually a pretty shy spider. Scientists have even done tests where they poke and prod her, trying to elicit a bite. And she turns to other defenses first, tries to run away, curls up into a little ball no bigger than a quarter. Sometimes she throws silk at the danger to try to escape. The bite is her last resort.
事实上，黑寡妇通常是相当害羞的蜘蛛。科学家们甚至做过测试，他们戳弄她，试图诱发她咬人。而她首先转向其他防御手段，试图逃跑，蜷缩成一个不比硬币大的小球。有时她会对威胁扔出丝线试图逃脱。咬人是她的最后手段。
So yeah. I think that the world should know that they've been lied to and that the black widow spider is not that bad.
所以是的。我认为世界应该知道他们一直被欺骗了，黑寡妇蜘蛛并没有那么坏。
And Kelsey has a proposal to set the record straight-- just change the spider's name, easy. Get rid of the name that mires her in all this twisted lore she doesn't deserve.
凯尔西有一个澄清事实的建议——改掉蜘蛛的名字，很简单。摆脱那个让她陷入所有这些不配拥有的扭曲传说中的名字。
I think that's what it looks like, renaming her. Black widow spiders were not always called black widow spiders. They've had many different names. Some of the names are the hourglass spider, the T-bar spider. The Miwok people, Indigenous to California, called the spider pokomoo.
我认为这就是重命名她的样子。黑寡妇蜘蛛并不总是叫黑寡妇蜘蛛。它们有很多不同的名字。其中一些名字是“沙漏蜘蛛”、“T型杆蜘蛛”。加州原住民米沃克人称这种蜘蛛为“pokomoo”。
The one she likes best, though--
不过，她最喜欢的一个名字是——
The shoe button spider.
鞋扣蜘蛛。
So cute.
太可爱了。
The shoe button spider, yeah.
鞋扣蜘蛛，是的。
She looks like a button, after all, a little round one.
毕竟，她看起来像个扣子，一个小圆扣子。
So I decided to test out this new name on the people I thought were the best suited to judge.
所以我决定在我觉得最适合判断的人身上测试这个新名字。
It was like my whole chest was in a vice grip.
感觉就像整个胸腔被虎钳夹住一样。
I spoke with eight people who'd been bitten, talked to 11 others over email. Here are some of them.
我采访了八个被咬过的人，通过电子邮件与另外11个人交流。以下是他们中的一些人。
Imagine the worst cramp that you've ever had in your life.
想象一下你一生中经历过的最严重的抽筋。
Like a Charley horse in your leg, but that being my whole back.
就像腿上抽筋，但我整个后背都是那样。
Like a really bad Charley horse that doesn't stop and envelops in your whole chest, right?
就像一种停不下来的、包裹着你整个胸腔的非常严重的抽筋，对吧？
I was twisting up my body, and I was holding onto the side panels of the vehicle and bracing myself when it was happening. And so weirdly enough, I wondered, is this what it feels like to go into labor?
我扭动着身体，抓着车辆的侧板，在发生这种情况时支撑自己。奇怪的是，我当时想，这是不是分娩的感觉？
Not everyone who's bit has a bad reaction like this. And again, bites are very rare. And a lot of the time, they're mild. But when it's bad, it's bad. So I ran Kelsey's idea by them. Do you think we should rename the black widow spider the shoe button spider? 13 people weighed in. No one was into it.
并非所有被咬的人都有这样糟糕的反应。而且再次说明，咬伤非常罕见。很多时候，它们都很轻微。但当严重时，真的很严重。所以我向他们征求了凯尔西的想法。你认为我们应该把黑寡妇蜘蛛重命名为鞋扣蜘蛛吗？13个人发表了意见。没人喜欢。
Oh my god. I do not-- I do not like that at all. No offense to the people who named that the shoe button spider back in the old days, but that is a very lame name.
天哪。我不想——我一点也不喜欢那个。对那些在老早以前把那个命名为鞋扣蜘蛛的人没什么冒犯的意思，但那个名字非常蹩脚。
This is Jenna. She got bit eight years ago in a porta potty at Coachella.
这是珍娜。她八年前在科切拉的一个移动厕所里被咬了。
Have you ever seen a black widow spider? They look cool. They are a spider you shouldn't mess with. And they probably have a bad rap. But I do like black widow. It gives it some power. And I think those spiders definitely have power.
你见过黑寡妇蜘蛛吗？它们看起来很酷。它们是你不要去惹的蜘蛛。而且它们可能名声不好。但我确实喜欢“黑寡妇”。它赋予了它一些力量。而且我认为那些蜘蛛绝对有力量。
Someone else who'd been bit told me, honestly, I think black widow is an excellent name. And were I a spider, I would feel really cool with a name like that.
另一个被咬的人告诉我，老实说，我认为“黑寡妇”是一个绝佳的名字。如果我是蜘蛛，拥有这样一个名字我会觉得真的很酷。
Lilly Sullivan is one of the producers of our show. Kelsey Padgett is hosting an upcoming podcast all about big rivalries in history and gossipy, petty feuds. It comes out next month. Keep your eyes out for that.
莉莉·沙利文是我们节目的制片人之一。凯尔西·帕吉特即将主持一个播客，全都是关于历史上大的竞争和爱传闲话的小家子气纠纷。下个月发布。敬请期待。
Coming up, Democrats and Republicans in Congress are doing such a great job coming to thoughtful, bipartisan solutions to our nation's problems. Let's see what they do with UFOs. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio, when our program continues.
接下来，国会的民主党人和共和党人正在非常出色地为我国的问题寻找深思熟虑、两党一致的解决方案。让我们看看他们是如何处理UFO的。芝加哥公共广播电台节目稍后继续。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today's program, setting the record straight, stories of people who feel very strongly that they have to clarify what's true and what's false about something very important to them. We have arrived at Act 3 of our program, Act 3, U-F-No.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天的节目，澄清事实，讲述那些感到必须澄清对自己非常重要的事情的真伪的人们的故事。我们已经到达了节目的第三幕，第三幕，U-F-No（不明飞行物不）。
So far today, we've heard a bunch of people setting the record straight on something. And now it is my pleasure to introduce our senior editor, David Kestenbaum, who's usually very measured. There's something he wants to get off his chest.
今天到目前为止，我们已经听了一群人为某件事澄清事实。现在我很高兴向大家介绍我们的资深编辑，大卫·克斯滕鲍姆，他通常非常稳重。他心里有些话想吐露。
The thing I'd like the record set straight on, UFOs are not real. They are not aliens from other planets come to visit us. Yes, I know, the Pentagon recently announced a new program to study weird stuff pilots are seeing. Yes, I know there was that super long New Yorker story. Or maybe you saw the 60 Minutes piece.
我想要澄清的一件事是，UFO不是真的。它们不是来自其他星球来访问我们的外星人。是的，我知道，五角大楼最近宣布了一项研究飞行员看到的奇怪东西的新计划。是的，我知道有一篇《纽约客》的长文。或者你可能看了《60分钟》的片段。
We have tackled many strange stories on 60 Minutes, but perhaps none like this.
我们在《60分钟》里处理过许多奇怪的故事，但也许没有像这样的。
It was pretty good TV.
那是相当不错的电视节目。
So what you're telling me is that UFOs, Unidentified Flying Objects, are real.
所以你告诉我的意思是，UFO，不明飞行物，是真的。
Bill, I think we're beyond that already.
比尔，我认为我们已经超越了那个讨论了。
Unidentified does not mean alien spacecraft. It means unidentified. Or maybe you saw these videos the Navy released.
“不明”并不意味着外星飞船。它意味着未被识别。或者你可能看了海军发布的这些视频。
There's a whole fleet of them. Look on the SA. My gosh. They're all going against the wind. The wind's 120 knots to the west. [INAUDIBLE].
它们有一整个舰队。看屏幕上。天哪。它们都在逆风飞行。风速是向西120节。[听不清]。
And even, even this guy.
甚至，甚至这个人。
What is true, and I'm actually being serious here--
事实是，我在这里是认真的——
--President Obama.
——奥巴马总统。
--there's footage and records of objects in the skies that we don't know exactly what they are. We can't explain how they moved, their trajectory. They did not have an easily explainable pattern.
——有镜头和记录显示天空中存在我们无法确切知道是什么的物体。我们无法解释它们是如何移动的，它们的轨迹。它们没有容易解释的模式。
Ugh. Particularly maddening are conversations I've had with people I know about this. And midway through, I realized, oh, I have to be polite because it's clear they think this is real. No more polite.
呕。特别让我生气的是我和我认识的人进行的关于这件事的对话。中途我意识到，噢，我得保持礼貌，因为很明显他们认为这是真的。不再礼貌了。
I have reasons for thinking all this is bullshit-- science reasons. For aliens to actually visit us, if they exist in the first place, they would either need to be insanely patient or be able to travel faster than the speed of light because the nearest stars are crazy far away.
我有理由认为所有这些都是胡说八道——科学理由。对于外星人如果存在的话，要真正访问我们，他们要么需要极其有耐心，要么需要能够以超光速旅行，因为最近的恒星距离远得疯狂。
I was a grad student in physics. I worked on one of those giant particle accelerators. And I can tell you, you can try to make those particles go as fast as you want. They get very close to the speed of light, but they do not go faster. We got to 99.999954% of the speed of light. You can double the amount of energy you're using, and it doesn't double the speed. It just gets you a tiny bit closer to the speed of light. The universe really does seem to have a speed limit. That's what the equations tell us. I mean, maybe there is some way around it, but it really, really does not seem like it.
我曾是一名物理学研究生。我在那些巨大的粒子加速器之一上工作过。我可以告诉你，你可以尝试让你想的那些粒子跑得尽可能快。它们可以非常接近光速，但它们跑不过光速。我们达到了光速的99.999954%。你可以加倍使用能量，但速度不会加倍。它只是让你离光速更近了一点点。宇宙确实似乎有一个速度限制。方程是这么告诉我们的。我的意思是，也许有某种绕过它的方法，但它看起来真的、真的没有办法。
And think about it for a second. In the '50s, it may be made sense that all the UFO photos were blurry and hard to decipher. But today, every single person with a smartphone has a super powerful camera in their pocket. That's billions of cameras. If alien spacecraft are here, shouldn't we have better pictures?
想一想吧。在50年代，所有UFO照片模糊且难以破译可能还有道理。但今天，每个拥有智能手机的人口袋里都有一个超级强大的相机。那是数十亿个相机。如果外星飞船在这里，我们难道不应该有更好的照片吗？
And the fact that basically no scientists seem interested in this at all and prefer to dwell on, say, detailed questions of how solar systems form, it tells you something. If any of these photos or radar blips or whatever really were alien craft, it would be the greatest discovery of all time. I can't think of a font big enough for the front page. But basically, every scientist in every university is sitting it out.
而且基本上没有科学家对这件事表现出任何兴趣，他们更喜欢沉浸在例如太阳系如何形成的详细问题上，这说明了什么。如果这些照片或雷达回波中的任何一个真的是外星飞船，那将是有史以来最伟大的发现。我想不出足够大的字体来印在头版。但基本上，每一所大学里的每一位科学家都在旁观。
As Neil deGrasse Tyson, the astrophysicist who runs the planetarium at the American Museum of Natural History, put it, he was talking about the people who believe these things are spaceships, quote, "The fact that you don't know what it is is not evidence that you know what it is, OK? You know why science exists?" he says. "Because the human sensory system sucks."
正如美国自然历史博物馆天文馆馆长、天体物理学家尼尔·德格拉塞·泰森所说，他在谈论那些相信这些东西是飞船的人时说：“你不知道它是什么，这并不是你知道它是什么的证据，好吗？你知道为什么科学存在吗？”他说，“因为人类的感觉系统太烂了。”
Unfortunately, with scientists off doing, you know, science, there is almost no one left to try to set the record straight, no one to quote in those news stories saying, you know, I think that's just a weather balloon. If they do quote someone, it's often this guy, Mick West.
不幸的是，科学家们都在做科学研究，几乎没有人去尝试澄清事实，没人去引用新闻故事里说的“你知道，我认为那只是一个气象气球”。如果他们确实引用了某人，那通常是这个人，米克·韦斯特。
I've looked at literally hundreds if not thousands of UFO cases because people send me them all the time, and there's always new ones coming up.
我看过字面意义上成百上千甚至上万个UFO案例，因为人们总是把它们发给我，而且总有新的案例出现。
Mick runs a website called Metabunk, where he and others try to really run these things down. Sometimes they figure out the object in the photo or video was a plane by finding the actual plane from maps and flight records.
米克运营着一个叫Metabunk的网站，他和别人尝试真正追踪这些事情。有时他们通过地图和飞行记录找到真实的飞机，从而弄清照片或视频中的物体是飞机。
Or one of my favorites, there was this photo of someone on a vacation took of these mysterious lights up in the sky over the water. Mick thought it looked like a reflection off the window. It was taken from inside. So he found the actual rental house based on the position of the mountains in the photo, called the homeowner, convinced her to take a photo from the same spot by the window, and confirmed, yes, a reflection of the living room lights.
或者我最喜欢的一个，有一张度假的人拍的照片，水面上空有神秘的光。米克认为它看起来像是窗户上的反射。那是从里面拍的。所以他根据照片中山脉的位置找到了那个真实的度假屋，打电话给房主，说服她从窗户旁边的同一个位置拍了一张照片，并确认，是的，客厅灯光的反射。
Most UFO cases are really, really simple and boring. Occasionally, though, you get an interesting one. And the most interesting ones are the ones that you get from the government.
大多数UFO案例真的、真的非常简单和无聊。不过，偶尔你会遇到一个有趣的。最有趣的是那些你从政府那里得到的。
I called Mick up earlier this year because something exciting was about to happen. There was going to be a congressional hearing on UFOs, the first in 50 years, which meant finally, the experts were going to weigh in, on the record, in front of Congress. This stuff, unexplained things seen by pilots or on radar, is usually secret. But now, we were going to hear from the people actually looking into these things, presumably with the help of the smartest scientists. I wanted them to set the record straight.
今年早些时候我给米克打了电话，因为一些令人兴奋的事情要发生了。国会将举行一场关于UFO的听证会，这是50年来的第一次，这意味着专家终于要作证了，记录在案，在国会面前。这种东西，飞行员看到或雷达上出现的无法解释的事情，通常是秘密的。但现在，我们要从那些真正研究这些事情的人那里听到了，大概在最聪明的科学家的帮助下。我想要他们澄清事实。
And in these partisan times when red and blue America seem to violently disagree about everything under the sun, this is one issue neither side has a stake in. Come on, America. Maybe we can agree on something. I would like that. I really would.
而在这种党派纷争的时代，红蓝美国似乎对太阳下的每一件事都持有极端的不同意见，这是唯一双方都没有利害关系的问题。来吧，美国。也许我们可以对某件事达成一致。我想要那样。我真的想要。
The morning of the hearing, Mick West and I got on a Zoom together to watch it live. He's on the West Coast, so it was little before 6:00 AM his time. We were waiting for it to start.
听证会那天早上，米克·韦斯特和我通过Zoom连线观看直播。他在西海岸，所以那是他当地时间早上6点之前。我们等着它开始。
How are you feeling about this thing?
你对这个事情感觉如何？
It's going to be very interesting. I suspect it's going to be a mixed bag.
这会非常有趣。我怀疑会是好坏参半。
I mean, for me, for me, I think unless they have a scientist there testifying, it could be very hard for me to watch.
我的意思是，对我来说，我认为除非他们有科学家在那里作证，否则我很难看下去。
Yeah. Well, I think what they're going to talk about is setting up the program and procedure.
是的。嗯，我认为他们会谈论的是建立程序和过程。
Oh, they're not going to talk about the evidence? They're not going to go over the actual--
噢，他们不谈论证据吗？他们不打算讨论实际的——
They are. I think they are. I heard this morning that this is new, that they may be sharing some video and talking about their analysis of the video, which, of course, is super interesting for me because I'm all about video analysis.
他们会的。我想会的。我今天早上听说这是新的，他们可能会分享一些视频并谈论他们对视频的分析，这当然对我来说超级有趣，因为我全神贯注于视频分析。
The feed of the hearing started.
听证会的信号开始了。
The subcommittee will come to order without obje--
小组委员会现在开会，如果没有异议——
Big formal hearing room on Capitol Hill, a couple of large American flags in the back.
国会山上的大型正式听证室，后面有几面美国大国旗。
More than 50 years ago, the US government ended Project Blue Book.
50多年前，美国政府结束了“蓝皮书计划”。
That's the chair of this House Intelligence subcommittee, Congressman Andre Carson, Democrat from Indiana. It was kind of weird and also delightful to hear a discussion of UFOs wrapped up in the formalism of a congressional hearing. It turns out, the government sorts through the question of whether we have been visited by aliens the same way it does any other problem. There's a task force, this one set up last November.
那是众议院情报小组委员会的主席，来自印第安纳州的民主党众议员安德烈·卡森。听到关于UFO的讨论被包裹在国会听证会的礼仪中，这很奇怪，也很有趣。事实证明，政府解决我们是否受到外星人访问的问题的方式与其他任何问题一样。有一个工作组，去年11月成立的那个。
--called the Airborne Object Identification and Management Synchronization Group, or AIMSOG.
——被称为“空中物体识别和管理同步小组”，简称AIMSOG。
[LAUGHS] So that's how you pronounce it.
[笑] 原来是这么发音的。
Today, we will bring that organization out of the shadows.
今天，我们将把那个组织带出阴影。
Yes. Bring it out of the shadows. There were two very high-ranking officials there to testify and answer questions from the lawmakers, Undersecretary of Defense for Intelligence and Security Ronald Moultrie, and Scott Bray, Deputy Director of Naval Intelligence. Bray laid out what the new task force was doing. They now have a formalized system for, say, pilots to report things they see and currently, a database of 400 incidents. They're going through them, trying to figure out what they are, as I hoped, working with all kinds of smart people.
是的。把它带出阴影。有两位级别非常高的官员到场作证，回答立法者的提问，负责情报和安全的国防部副部长罗纳德·穆特里，以及海军情报副局长斯科特·布雷。布雷阐述了新工作组正在做什么。他们现在有了一个正式的系统供飞行员报告所见所闻，目前有一个包含400起事件的数据库。他们正在梳理这些事件，试图弄清它们是什么，正如我所希望的那样，与各种聪明人合作。
--subject matter experts from a wide variety of fields, including physics, optics, metallurgy, meteorology.
——来自物理学、光学、冶金学、气象学等各个领域的专家。
UFOs, by the way, have now been rebranded UAPs, Unidentified Aerial Phenomena, I think so pilots won't be embarrassed to report sightings. The military does have real concerns.
顺便说一下，UFO现在已经更名为UAP，不明空中现象，我想这样飞行员就不会因为报告目击事件而感到尴尬了。军方确实有真正的担忧。
Incursions in our training ranges by unidentified objects represent serious hazards to safety of flight.
不明物体对我们训练范围的入侵构成了严重的飞行安全隐患。
Bray said there are several categories of what these things could be, airborne clutter, like a balloon, atmospheric phenomena, some weather thing. They could be something of ours, maybe a drone, something from one of our adversaries, which might pose a national security threat, or one final category, a bin he called other, which, quote, "allows for the possibility of surprise and scientific discovery." He did not seem to want to say aliens. Then things got interesting. Bray turned to a screen in the hearing room.
布雷说，这些东西可能有几种类别，空中杂物，比如气球，大气现象，某种天气情况。它们可能是我们的东西，比如无人机，来自我们对手的东西，这可能构成国家安全威胁，或者最后一个类别，一个他称为“其他”的类别，报价说“允许惊喜和科学发现的可能性”。他似乎不想说外星人。然后事情变得有趣了。布雷转向听证室里的屏幕。
In this video, US Navy personnel recorded what appears to be triangles, some flashing, recorded several years ago off the coast of the United States.
在这个视频中，美国海军人员记录下了看似三角形的东西，有些在闪烁，是几年前在海岸外记录的。
This is a video that had been leaked a while ago but never explained. It's wild-looking. The footage is green because it's shot with night vision goggles. And what you see are these very clear triangles. They really appear to be some sort of triangular craft blinking. Mick was not impressed.
这是一个以前泄露但从未得到解释的视频。它看起来很疯狂。镜头是绿色的，因为它是用夜视镜拍摄的。你看到的是非常清晰的三角形。它们看起来确实像是某种闪烁的三角形飞行器。米克没被打动。
[LAUGHS] This video is bullshit. This essentially is a camera artifact, so it's probably a plane.
[笑] 这个视频是胡说八道。这基本上是一个相机伪影，所以它很可能是一架飞机。
A camera artifact. Mick claims they're not really triangle-shaped. He thinks it's a kind of optical illusion created by the camera itself. Next, Bray shows a still image with another mysterious green triangle, just like the ones in the video.
一个相机伪影。米克声称它们不是真的三角形。他认为这是一种由相机本身产生的视觉错觉。接下来，布雷展示了一张静止图像，上面有另一个神秘的绿色三角形，就像视频里的那些。
Several years later and off a different coast, US Navy personnel again, through night vision goggles and an SLR camera, recorded this image. But this time, other US Navy assets also observed unmanned aerial systems nearby.
几年后，在另一个海岸外，美国海军人员再次通过夜视镜和单反相机记录下了这张图像。但这次，其他美国海军资产也在附近观察到了无人机系统。
Meaning drones or something like that. Bray says they're what the camera was seeing.
意思是无人机之类的东西。布雷说，它们就是相机看到的东西。
The triangular appearance is a result of light passing through the night vision goggles and then being recorded by an SLR camera.
三角形的出现是光线通过夜视镜然后被单反相机记录下来的结果。
Thank you. Excellent. [LAUGHS]
谢谢。棒极了。[笑]
How did you feel about that? He just showed the video, and it looked really bad, and then he actually explained it.
你感觉如何？他刚展示了视频，看起来很糟糕，然后他真的解释了。
Yeah, that's great. That's something-- I've been talking about that video for well over a year now. And right from the-- 10 seconds after the video was posted, I recognized what it was and posted that it was just a camera artifact.
是的，那太棒了。那是某种——我谈论那个视频已经一年多了。在视频发布后的10秒钟，我就认出了它是什么，并发布说它只是一个相机伪影。
But no one in the government has said that.
但政府里没人那么说。
No, no one said that. And the person who leaked it has been vehemently insisting that there's actual pyramid-shaped craft flying around and that I'm completely wrong. But now Scott Bray has just explained that I was correct, which is great. Put that one to rest.
不，没人那么说。而那个泄露它的人一直强烈坚持说周围有真正的金字塔形飞行器在飞，而且我是完全错误的。但现在斯科特·布雷刚解释说我是正确的，这太棒了。让那个结束吧。
One record set straight, one unidentified flying object identified. Scott Bray showed another video, which he said was more typical. This was one Mick hadn't seen. It was new. It hadn't been previously released.
澄清了一个记录，识别了一个不明飞行物。斯科特·布雷展示了另一个视频，他说那是更典型的。这是一个米克没见过的。它是新的。它以前没被发布过。
--which shows an observation in real time.
——展示了一个实时观察。
All right. What is this?
好了。这是什么？
This one is from an F-18. It's shot out the window with what seems like someone's phone. And for the tiniest fraction of a second, something flits by. It's there, and then it's gone.
这个是从F-18上拍的。它是用手机之类的东西从窗外拍的。在万分之一秒内，有什么东西飞过。它在那里，然后消失了。
There it was.
就在那儿。
What was-- I didn't--
那是什么——我没——
In many cases, that's all that a report may include.
在很多情况下，报告可能只包含这些。
Dang it. I didn't see it. Show it again.
该死。我没看到。再放一遍。
Mick gets his wish.
米克达成了愿望。
Mr. Bray, can you rerun that first image that looked like it was outside of a plane window?
布雷先生，你能把刚才那个看起来在飞机窗外的第一张图再放一遍吗？
Congressman Adam Schiff, Democrat from California, Chair of the House Intelligence Committee.
众议员亚当·希夫，来自加利福尼亚的民主党人，众议院情报委员会主席。
And if you wouldn't mind going up to the screen and tell us what we're seeing, explain what we should be looking at in that first image.
如果你不介意走到屏幕前告诉我们我们看到了什么，解释我们应该在那张第一张图中看什么。
Absolutely.
当然可以。
It turns out the technical capability of the US military has its limits. They have a real hard time stopping the video at the exact frame where this thing flashes by. They try for four minutes.
事实证明，美国军方的技术能力是有极限的。他们很难在东西闪过的精确帧上停止视频。他们尝试了四分钟。
OK. If you could stop that frame.
好的。如果你能停止那一帧。
That's not the one.
不是那一帧。
This is terrible video, a terrible example. It's almost certainly a balloon, airborne clutter. It's not demonstrating any advanced maneuvering or anything.
这是个糟糕的视频，一个糟糕的例子。它几乎可以肯定是气球，空中杂物。它没展示出任何先进的机动动作之类的。
What you see here is an aircraft that is operating in a US Navy training range that has observed a spherical object in that area. And as they fly by it, they take a video. You see, it looks reflective in this video, somewhat reflective.
你在这里看到的是一架在美国海军训练区操作的飞机，它在那个区域观察到了一个球形物体。当他们飞过它时，他们拍了一个视频。你看，它在视频里看起来是反光的，某种程度上反光。
Somewhat reflective because it's a mylar balloon.
某种程度上反光，因为那是个麦拉气球。
And it quickly passes by the cockpit of the aircraft.
它迅速经过了飞机的驾驶舱。
And is this one of the phenomena that we can't explain?
这就是我们无法解释的现象之一吗？
I do not have an explanation for what this specific object is.
对于这个特定物体是什么，我没有解释。
And is this one of the situations where-- that's the object that we're looking at right there? Thank you. And is this a situation where it was observed by the pilot, and it was also recorded by the aircraft's instruments?
这就是那种情况吗——那就是我们在那儿看到的物体？谢谢。这是那种由飞行员观察到，也被飞机仪器记录下来的情况吗？
We'll talk about the multisensor part in a later session.
我们将在以后的会议中谈论多传感器部分。
Later session means the behind closed doors part, where they go over all the classified stuff. Translation, they have other data, radar or some advanced sensing, that who knows, maybe gives them a pretty good idea of what this is or what it isn't. But because it's classified, they can't talk about it.
以后的会议意味着闭门会议部分，他们去讨论所有机密的东西。翻译一下，他们有其他数据，雷达或其他高级感应，谁知道呢，也许让他们很清楚那是什么或不是什么。但因为它是机密的，他们不能说。
Not helpful.
没用。
And then this happened. Mike Gallagher, Republican from Wisconsin, asked a bunch of questions of Bray and also Undersecretary Moultrie. And he seems to be in prosecutor mode, like he's trying to get something important on the record. Basically, do you know of any other programs currently looking into UAPs? Answer, no. Any ones from the past decades we don't know about? No. Then this.
然后发生了这件事。来自威斯康星州的共和党人迈克·加拉格尔向布雷和副部长穆特里问了一堆问题。他似乎处于检察官模式，好像在试图在记录上得到什么重要的东西。基本上，你知道目前有其他研究UAP的计划吗？回答，没有。过去几十年有什么我们不知道的计划吗？没有。然后是这个。
It's also been reported that there have been UAP observed and interacting with and flying over sensitive military facilities, particularly-- and not just ranges, but some facilities housing our strategic nuclear forces. One such incident allegedly occurred at Malmstrom Air Force Base, in which 10 of our nuclear ICBMs were rendered inoperable. At the same time, a glowing red orb was observed overhead. I'm not commenting on the accuracy of this. I'm saying--
也有报道称有UAP在敏感的军事设施上空观察、互动和飞行，特别是——不仅是训练范围，还有一些安置我们战略核力量的设施。据称其中一起事件发生在马尔姆斯特罗姆空军基地，其中10枚我们的核洲际弹道导弹失效了。与此同时，头顶上空观察到一个发光的红色球体。我不是在评论这个报道的准确性。我说的是——
This is a big part of UFO mythology.
这是UFO神话的很大一部分。
Do you have any comment on the accuracy of that report?
你对那个报告的准确性有什么评论吗？
Let me pass that to Mr. Bray. You've been looking at UAPs over the last three years.
让我把它传给布雷先生。你在过去三年一直在看UAP。
That data is not within the holdings of the UAP Task Force.
那些数据不在UAP工作组的持有范围内。
OK. But are you aware of the report?
好的。但你知道那个报告吗？
I have heard stories. I have not seen the official data on that.
我听说过故事。我没见过关于那个的官方数据。
Well, I would say-- I mean, it's a pretty high-profile incident. I don't claim to be an expert on this, but that's out there in the ether. You're the guys investigating it. I mean, who else is doing it?
嗯，我会说——我的意思是，这是一个相当引人注目的事件。我不自称是这个方面的专家，但它在以太中传播。你们是调查它的家伙。我的意思是，还有谁在做这个？
If something was officially brought to our attention, we would look at it. There are many things that are out there in the ether that aren't officially brought to our attention.
如果有东西被正式带到我们的注意范围内，我们会看它。在以太中有许多东西没被正式带到我们的注意范围内。
So how would it have to be officially brought to your-- I'm bringing it to your attention. This is pretty official.
那么它怎么必须正式带到你们的——我把它带到你们的注意范围内。这相当正式。
Sure. So we'll go back and take a look at it. But generally, there is some authoritative figure that says there is an incident that occurred. We'd like you to look at this.
当然。所以我们会回去看看。但通常，有某种权威人物说发生了一个事件。我们想让你看看这个。
Well, I don't claim to be an authoritative figure, but for what it's worth, I would like you to look into it, if for no other reason--
嗯，我不自称是一个权威人物，但不管怎么说，我希望你们去调查一下，如果仅仅为了——
Now, there was something that needed explaining. A red orb? Nuclear ICBMs becoming inoperable? I figured there must be data on that-- cell phone video, radar, computer records. But Mick explained that there wouldn't be. This incident, it allegedly happened in the 1960s.
现在，有一件事需要解释。一个红色的球体？核洲际弹道导弹失效？我想一定有关于那个的数据——手机视频、雷达、电脑记录。但米克解释说不会有。这个事件，据称发生在20世纪60年代。
We will recess this hearing and return in a closed session at noon.
我们将休会，并在中午返回闭门会议。
Oh, there we go.
噢，就这样了。
Then it was over, the first UFO hearing in Congress in 50 years. Mick and I had different reactions to the hearing. He thought it went fine.
然后结束了，50年来国会的第一次UFO听证会。米克和我的反应不同。他认为还可以。
I thought this hearing was good in that we did get some new data out. I think it was fairly well-balanced. And they talked a lot about the process that they're going to set up.
我认为这次听证会很好，因为我们确实得到了一些新数据。我认为它相当平衡。他们谈了很多他们将要建立的程序。
I was pretty frustrated. I'd wanted someone to say, look, there is no reason to think any of these things are alien spacecraft. Or we do not have definitive evidence of anything that violates the laws of physics. Mick wanted that last one too, actually. We didn't get it.
我很沮丧。我想要有人说，看，没有理由认为这些东西中的任何一个是外星飞船。或者我们没有确凿的证据证明任何违反物理定律的东西。其实米克也想要最后那一点。我们没得到。
How do you feel about the unending nature of this? You know what I mean? Everyone's going to walk away from every one of these hearings believing exactly whatever they want.
你对这个事情没完没了的性质感觉如何？你知道我的意思吗？每个人都会从这些听证会中走出来，相信他们想相信的任何东西。
Yeah, yeah.
是的，是的。
People who want to believe in aliens will say, look, we had a hearing. This is real. And people like you are going to say, look, they showed that video and actually explained what it was. See?
想要相信外星人的人会说，看，我们开了一次听证会。这是真的。而像你这样的人会说，看，他们展示了那个视频并真正解释了它是什么。看到了吗？
Yeah. It never ends. But it's a topic that's impossible to end because there's always going to be unidentified flying objects.
是的。它永远不会结束。但这是一个不可能结束的话题，因为总会有不明飞行物。
This is a horrible thought that I hadn't really grappled with. There will always be blurry photos of things in the sky, probably more now that everyone has a cell phone with them all the time. So there really is only one way the record will ever get set straight, that we will get an answer to whether aliens are here on Earth. And that's if we actually find them. In other words, the believers can win. My side can't. You can never prove aliens aren't here. But I'm telling you, they're not.
这是一个我还没真正深入思考过的可怕想法。天空中永远会有模糊的照片，可能现在更多了，因为每个人手机里都有相机。所以确实只有一种方式真相大白，即我们要得到关于外星人是否在地球上的答案。那就是如果我们真的找到了他们。换句话说，相信的人可以赢。我这方不能。你永远无法证明外星人不在。但我告诉你，他们不在。
David Kestenbaum is our program's senior editor.
大卫·克斯滕鲍姆是我们节目的资深编辑。
[MUSIC - "TELL THE TRUTH" BY JON BATISTE]
[音乐 - 乔恩·巴蒂斯特的《说出真相》]
Our program was produced today by Chris Benderev. People who put together today's program include Sean Cole, Michal Comite, Aviva DeKornfeld, Chana Joffe-Walt, Tobin Low, Stowe Nelson, Katherine Rae Mondo, Nadia Reiman, Marisa Robertson-Textor, Ryan Rumery, Charlotte Sleeper, Frances Swanson, Christopher Swetala, Matt Tierney, Julie Whitaker, and Diane Wu. Our managing editor is Sarah Abdurrahman. Our senior editor is David Kestenbaum. Our executive editor is Emanuele Berry.
今天的节目由克里斯·本德雷夫制作。组建今天节目的人包括肖恩·科尔、米哈尔·科米特、阿维瓦·德科恩菲尔德、查娜·乔夫-沃尔特、托宾·洛、斯托·尼尔森、凯瑟琳·雷·蒙多、纳迪亚·雷曼、玛丽莎·罗伯逊-泰克斯特、瑞安·鲁梅里、夏洛特·斯利珀、弗朗西斯·斯旺森、克里斯托弗·斯韦塔拉、马特·蒂尔尼、朱莉·惠特克和黛安·吴。我们的主编是萨拉·阿卜杜拉赫曼。我们的资深编辑是大卫·克斯滕鲍姆。我们的执行编辑是埃马努埃莱·贝里。
Special thanks today to Jackson Landers, Liz Hanes, Jill Cashen, Laura Spiri, Meg Freyermuth, Jenna Kagel, Katherine Perkins, and Dr. Catherine Scott, who is a scientist who helped us so much with the black widow story. If you want to read more about black widow behavior and misinformation, check out Dr. Scott's blog, spiderbytes.org. That's spiderB-Y-T-E-S.org.
特别感谢杰克逊·兰德斯、利兹·海恩斯、吉尔·卡申、劳拉·斯皮里、梅格·弗雷穆斯、珍娜·凯格尔、凯瑟琳·珀金斯和凯瑟琳·斯科特博士，她是一位帮助我们完成黑寡妇故事的科学家。如果你想阅读更多关于黑寡妇行为和错误信息的内容，请访问斯科特博士的博客spiderbytes.org。即spiderB-Y-T-E-S.org。
Our website, thisamericanlife.org. You can stream our archive of over 750 episodes for absolutely free. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks, as always, to a program's cofounder Mr. Torey Malatia. Even though he's management, he decided he wanted to run for shop steward. Always wanted to be part of the union. Kind of a weird dream, but he says--
我们的网站，thisamericanlife.org。你可以免费在线收听我们750多集的档案。本节目由PRX公共广播交易台提供给公共广播电台。像往常一样，感谢节目的共同创始人托里·马拉蒂亚先生。即使他是管理层，他也决定想竞选工会代表。一直想成为工会的一部分。有点奇怪的梦想，但他说——
I kind of wondered, is this what it feels like to go into labor?
我有点想知道，这是不是分娩的感觉？
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories for This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周回来，带来更多《美国生活》的故事。
(SINGING) He said, tell it like it is. Da-da-da-da-da. Do it like [INAUDIBLE].
（唱歌）他说，实话说出来。达达达达达。做出来像[听不清]。
[VOCALIZING]
[吟唱]
When you do what you do, do-do.
当你做你做的事时，做做。